did you feel your right hand shake
yes and you're
pushing h
you're unsure of what to uh what you're
feeling for this is how you try
different
feelings your right hand shook too did
you feel it
yes and your in her shoulders so she's
pushing into your shoulders per
prescription and you did it right back
to her that that is the ego
tripartite still in her
shoulders she she is shoving you can see
she has a linear line into my shoulders
so that energy goes
down my hands
don't have to shap they don't have to
get tension you you you're now
being contaged by my
relaxation do you understand but your
prescription is not to relax okay so as
you feel as you feel my tension go away
in my body you don't let that happen to
you per prescription Okay so
no matter what then don't aim that into
her
shoulders it goes down into her Center
you see that little kind of
thing right there you're in your
Center not up
here if you pay attention because
because she's pushing in hard her core
will lock on her okay but if I push at
the top of this it kind of just tilts
her you see but once I go into her
Center you'll see that the pelvis kind
of caves like that you see that caves
like that and if you can't see it you
can get closer over here maybe from this
angle you can see her
bels her belt knot so here she's locked
because that's what happens when you try
to be strong if I just push the top of
this lever it just tilts her but I want
to go into that center right
there there so here it is from an angle
you see it kind of turns straight
in the angle turnning see so that
that'll always
happen as I do this row even when it
looks like I'm going in her shoulder you
should always there it is right
there there it is right there so for me
it's
like UND it this is
C this is just arm
wrestling
and because that's my only goal it
doesn't matter what I do with my arms do
you
see understand so I don't have to do the
keyhole do you
understand but if I was to do the Keon
it's the same way into the
center into the center not out
top not out
top does that make
sense okay let's
uh aim
differently
okay so
again to do a
drill you have to follow the
prescriptions
just like if I'm going to do bench
press my bar is prescribed not to bend
or break the barbell do you
see oh if I start doing something
outside the prescription I can't do the
drill then I cannot get the desired
effect from drilling okay now there's
all kinds of things because in the nag
UK
relationship the UK
is also working on something okay not
they're not a a passive receiver that
just this is not correct okay they're
going to receive the energy the Yang
energy of
Nag and they're going to reconcile that
energy through the same internal process
that Naga first reconciled the
prescribed Yang energy that UK was doing
but what happened
is out of the ego
tripartite
and it's fuel or it's it's being fueled
by fear is once the UK feels a any sort
of transition from the initial Yong
prescription they now will subvert the
drill as they do something else okay so
the most obvious one is the beginner
that uh
will stop pushing because they realize
holy cow I'm adding inertia momentum to
the projection do you see
okay uh this one is very subtle but it
is there okay so you do the initial Yang
push but as soon as you feel your Center
you just you you stop you start yielding
do do you understand um and that's
creating a false
success okay
so and again this is why you need a
teacher cuz that look that
looks close didn't it you're making his
Center move you see that but a teacher
can tell that from the way your whole
body was
organized that you you wouldn't even
have the ability to project that that
Center that he took away the prescribed
Yang energy remember how Virginia
remained locked
do you see she hence when I pushed on
her shoulders she just tilted see um had
she not remained locked when you push on
my shoulders right her knees would have
stayed down do you
see so what happens is as you go as as I
feel you trying to get in my Center then
I disengage the center you see that so
the teacher could see that this
posture and the vectors that she
attempted to go into your
Center uh are not truly viable so if I
just continue the
prescription instead of when I feel her
do you see if I disc continue the
prescription so none of this is going in
the ground so you we're going to prolong
it okay I'm I'm just matching your young
energy okay just stay
here what is happening uh you're not
moving okay what else do you feel in
your body uh tension in my arms okay do
you feel I'm just matching your energy
yes I'm do you feel the fatigue setting
do you see so we stay here forever I'm
going to be here for forever so I just
have the I adhesion but you're basically
doing deltoid bicep and you see that
you're going into a fatigue State see
that you're going to get burnt out
pretty soon do you
see you see yes I'm there there he is
okay whereas if we do it the other way
and you're pushing
keep
pushing keep P I'll put my arms wherever
you want no you're going to keep pushing
keep pushing I have some weird
mechanical
disadvantage there's that fatigue did
you feel it yes it I'll just keep
matching
you there it is you see you're weakening
you're fatiguing cuz it's in your
arms do you see you got you petered out
okay so for her to get a a reasonable
feedback on what you're actually
doing you have to keep your prescription
so I I don't do anything asuk except the
prescription
until this is all shoulder you see yes
okay so maybe try try the external deep
leveraging and same thing I don't go ah
K
Takei I keep the
prescription you see that arm watch
watch me go as a
UK ah K you see okay so instead it's a
prescription and you can now you can
feel a I am in my deltoid and this
arm has gone just pretty much like from
Z to one 10 and 10 is maximum power this
arm is floating around 5.1 you see it
went dead you see that yes you get that
so there's barely anything on it okay
because this Drew all your attention so
as opposed if you keep pushing again
like you're going to fatigue your arms
then I can do my J right whereas watch
if you as you feel me get into your
Center do you see I want you to now
disengage from the prescription right
when you feel that and now this is not
training do you understand
yes so she pushes the whole time pushes
the whole
time never taking care of yourself so
usually you the the the UK will go off
poke you whole cuz they're afraid to
fall but you're only you're not going to
fall hard okay so the whole time you
push you
push get back in here get you're too far
away all that is freightin you're going
to
push
better no there's no need to touch on
the ground cuz you're not falling
hard good you you win a little right
there that's you disengage you see so
that's just stay there in that
disengaged State you got it that's why I
can me
you so I'll we'll get there cosmetically
okay let's go this way for the camera
okay so get you're going to do it
externally see okay right I want to get
in that teeter totter position so you're
pushing don't push past me till I get
there don't push past me till I hit
there just don't collapse here but don't
shove into positive stay right there and
I'm going to get in that position you
were you see try to e me
in you see yes I just still project now
watch you get me in that precarious
position and you feel that yes I now
step in you say oh okay so first of
all people that are doing asocial
violence they don't they don't do that
self- protection thing okay but we're
now not doing the drill and we get false
positives okay that's why you need the
teacher but the weak Link in the system
is you have to do what the teacher says
even against your
instincts your instincts are fear-based
at this point do you
understand
okay do that same side I'll be over
here look did you see your right hand
travel towards her so I want you to to
demonstrate what I am trying to key in
on your it's in your right hand you're
going to talk me what's my point
that I can't I'm
externally holding up
no what happened is this hand moved
towards her and her Center didn't move
okay do you see that which means you're
external you're not in her Center do you
see that flip floppy yes
okay we just do this so you see this
this part you see
that
so this
has
to uh stay here but go there you
understand so I you were first in the
before we filmed you were
materially
conceiving that you push here you see
but you have stopped the prescription
you're no longer engaged in pushing you
see that okay so if you keep that
pushing and I do what you did you'll be
able to push my hand down you see okay
whereas if I keep the
extension
and you push down push down push down
don't
disengage push down push down you see
now watch your
body so you your hand was not able to
get that Yin space which it would always
be able to do if I'm just
moving your wrist you see that so same
thing happens
here even though I'm here I don't
go okay it goes in your I'm in your body
so for example I'll take you this
way bring it
back not
here boom and disconnection point in
your
body here should
be when you disengage and stay at your
wrist you can shove
down yes shove down all you
want got it you're going to shove down
all you but look at your look at your
and you can do it you're shoving down
and you can do it
any you can go the other way see your
elbow you're going to take away all
mechanical advantage if you pay
attention I do you this way now so
instead of leaving this
up the kind
of just flip
so
flip
push sit
here this angle should be more
impossible you see but no it's in your
[Music]
butt so if you're do in the
Keyon once you got here what what you're
doing in the Keyon is it it integrates
the external you see so you cannot push
as hard you see that as opposed to your
hair you can push pretty dang hard right
you understand so I
combined and integrate the external I
put you at a more mechanical
disadvantage but I don't want want to go
external
external when you
integrate not
here leave it take some energy off but
here we're in that
same in your body not in your arms
when when I'm in your arms you're in my
arms you see and that's why shove down
when you
want
okay